the new true Sun's leader General
Anderson has finally come out of hiding
to finalize negotiations with Natalia
Sokolova after realizing the true sons
have no chance against both the division
and the Black Tusk he is organizing an
alliance with the btsu leader
our job is to stop that from happening
[Music]
[Music]
General Peter Anderson believed with
every bone in his body that he was an
exceptional being an extraordinary man
yet in reality this was just not the
case but oftentimes the way in which a
person of his egotistic mindset views
themselves with such high regard can
have a Monumental impact on those around
them
he sought immense value in establishing
and maintaining closeness with those in
positions of authority and control
Anderson was consumed with the idea of
procuring heist status for himself and
it's what drove him over almost anything
else and what fundamentally controlled a
lot of his actions
he proved himself countless times to
others that he was more than just a
simple paper pusher and served his
country in the Army the Army Reserves
and the National Guard
in school he surrounded himself with
charming popular individuals in order to
study how they were able to acquire that
social currency after being mercilessly
teased as a child for having a fixation
on order and proficiency
realizing that charismatic individuals
are really interested in the process he
saw an opportunity to position himself
as the man who knew where everybody was
interred and how the system functioned
allowing the leaders to project Charisma
while he maintained the true power
behind the scenes
Anderson can now use his years of
research into the narcissistic mentality
to his Advantage now that Ridgeway is no
longer with them and the true sons are
seeking guidance
Anderson will take the true Sons
Nationwide whereas ridgeway's Vision was
always limited and small
he'll establish a network Across the
Nation portray Ridgeway as a martyr and
demonize the division using his death
I'm pleased we could come to some sort
of arrangement Ms Sokolova please call
me Natalya oh very well Natalia Carl
speaks very highly of you General uh
Peter please very well Peter
I'm sorry about all of that confusion at
Bonnie's test oh no I'm the one who
should apologize I had no idea our goals
were so aligned the trouble with Black
Ops you never know if you're secretly
shooting at your backup
that's true I hope we can be more candid
now that's the other trouble with Black
Ops candid is kind of outside the job
description
I understand do you not really but I
will I like a man who can admit when
he's wrong well you should be careful
you might fall in love with me then you
shouldn't try to be funny
it doesn't suit you
you don't want any stationary basis I
find my teams are more effective as a
mobile unit we would maintain the ground
force and infrastructure and you would
run the trade routes and supply lines
exactly
think of your true Sons like the
skeleton and we are the blood we are
critical to maintaining structural
support true Sons will handle territory
control and Black Tusk Mobile support we
enhance one another's strengths to
protect from external forces who would
prey on our weaknesses they're smarter
than I thought well
thank you Natalya Peter
it's nothing
Anderson and Natalya discuss the finer
details behind their Alliance in one of
the more Awkward interactions I've heard
in a while
clear that Anderson is out of his depth
and that his position in this Alliance
is going to be placed heavily under
Natalia's thumb
the true Sons will be placed on guard
duty while Natalia's Black Tusk run
operations
how is Captain Lewis finding his new
accommodation
Fred is finding his quarters a bit
cramped and inhospitable but livable and
the rest of his friends
some have retired most are enjoying
similar accommodations and a few have
refused our invitation how many is a few
so far only one can be confirmed Wally
yes Natalia Wally was on a supply run
and has eluded our patrols it's a shame
she was one of our best engineers
no matter
I'm sure she will be easily replaceable
I look forward to getting the full tour
as soon as you've cleared up your rat
problem
so the soldiers that Captain Lewis have
been preparing for the transfer over to
the division have been rounded up and
either locked away or executed
rescuing Lewis May provide the
opportunity to pull the remaining true
Sons still loyal to him out if it's not
too late
after the division had finished dealing
with Natalya's Black Tusk operatives who
were sent in to assist the true Sons
agents would discover General Anderson's
location at the pintco Fairview power
plant where he had a meeting planned
with Natalia Sokolova when the agents
arrived on site Anderson was assigned a
security detail by Natalya who would be
responsible for getting him safely to
The Docks but also stopping the agents
from rescuing Lewis
running through various challenges
including EMP Jammers that were set up
in the laboratory and Rising steam
pressure in the cooling tower agents
would make their way to the reactor
there Lewis has been locked away in the
office while btsu operatives activated a
Fail-Safe setting the building on fire
after deactivating the fire suppression
system
division agents were successful in
turning on the valves and reactivating
the sprinklers rescuing Lewis in the
process but with little warning Lewis
took off in pursuit of Anderson
however Anderson had already made it to
the docks where Natalia had arrived with
hovercrafts
the agents would meet up with Lewis in
the parking lot where a helicopter was
waiting to extract them
go for Lewis
no negative
start with the risk there's a fleet of a
black dust hovercraft this fog is the
only reason why your extraction is still
breathing
not that well I don't think England does
you've only met 5
. she was
expected
thank you and your boys for the assist
I look forward to working with you now
that we're Partners she looked like the
president of the PTA
[Music]
now there is the slight pickup that the
division took the plant
but I'm not concerned they've most
likely moved on to their next assignment
we'll regroup and take back what is
rightfully ours
and
my true sons are at your disposal and
ready to follow your orders excellent
let's get to work
so we didn't manage to catch up with
General Anderson and put a stop to his
true Sons merging with the Black Tusk
but we managed to rescue Lewis and
potentially the remaining true Sons
loyal to him too
hard to say whether we've taken back the
Fairview power plant as there seemed to
be a huge number of them still piling
out when we were extracted but I like to
think that they are now at least aware
of how insecure it is this is the shd I
mean I guess we've had a lot of practice
with the countdown game mode
otherwise I thoroughly enjoyed that
final mission I generally don't like
timed missions but I loved how
challenging this was I actually have to
go back and play it on heroic I couldn't
manage to complete it on time on my own
and needed to get the footage for this
video so sadly I had to do it on
challenging
anyway thank you very much for watching
and extremist malice extremely remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign